station this station is is the title is
moving forward with darkness it it is
different to your your menu because i
change this topic and content because I
confront I one but so so I can I change
a little lace oh so you receive the
different topic topic in your manual but
I will deliver it is this wish moving
forward through darkness yeah we do a
lot of data mining every day when we are
we are doing the remaining just light is
too so to solve the real business
problem it's just like moving forward
the darkness most of time we didn't know
which is the right duration which is
Elaine at the answer to the business
program the most of time we only have
the potential duration and we can try
and follow so so like that we cannot see
the true answer so most of them just
like this you can now see the future you
can ask you can only see the thing in
front of you so you cannot know what is
the restore involve you in the future we
always work working with the uncertainty
in our daily life we always moving
forwards with darkness to writings so
just as I like today I was showing you
that how I break through the brightness
of the modeling of the machine learning
and data mine model when you are going
to use the model to solve your piston
program hi I'm George I came from Taiwan
then and I have a lot of experience in
quantitative trading and incomers
consulting and also have a lot of trying
to build a recommendation sittin in
search engine and the most important
thing is i love python and I want to
share price on to everyone to to help
their daily life so so this is why I
here okay back to the topic I want to
show you training model from data is
just just like schedule picture from the
words it's just like imaging when you
are sketching of an April you you from
the microstructure to a microstructure
so you you fought you Jorah ship and in
the Jura shuttle and the luminous it
just like when you are doing your
modeling job look most famous Pender
Jackson peroxide lepen has its life of
its own I just try to let it come
through I think of the data scientist we
have those thing words but the data has
its own life and that we just try to let
a canceled so how to let go data cancer
is just like staging like we can see
there are a lot of people in this they
are trying to schedule the tree English
danger and lately listen on the
different angles the first off save of
staging scheduling is not picking up
your pin it's choosing an angle and do
some observation it's just like we do we
always do the exponent of the external
they all notice when we try a new data
we will not do a heavy analysis so just
like this now the object changing from
the tree into your data is just like
this it's your your object you need to
do some picture of your object so how
can how can we draw we can do a lot lies
realized and it has the soul and also
Incept so we can prod I realize as a
point on your right hand side so
remember that there is there are a lot
of lies and the point and though which
is a motor similar word which is the
most a similar enter pinned to the tree
we need to choose an angle and the part
of the angle means in linear regression
is its objective function so the
objective function define which plant is
most similar to to the object and its
defined which line is mostly most
optimizer to your objective function so
you can sure also to your objective
function because it's a simple linear
regression just we single dimension
input so posting postings together you
can see that in your left hand side
there is a lot of layers of data here
and also a lot of ice just like your
repent to Allah tree and and there
there's a lot of picture here just like
the lines over the data so when we want
to define which is the most similar
things we need to choose an angle so
like the boy he chose this angle maybe
he will sing louder her hand is not a
single to a tree but hurt happened is
just a represent an audible is a lower
so so so so the same thing in energy hub
mining and data analysis after you
choose an angle you can solve the
atomizer from gradient descent no matter
what you use linear regression or no
matter what you use deep learning it was
then you can use stochastic gradient
descent two easiest of your model after
you write down the objective function
so how do we change our angle from the
linear regression program you can add
the weighted to your data because just
like I I try to control a lot of trading
strategy in of option Marquis and future
market some of data are most important
to the others because some of they have
makes you earn a lot of money or do so
long money it's much important to the
data let's make you earn small money and
that you lose more money so some is
important so so you should not to turn
your model with the equal weight yeah
you should turn your model with
different weights after you add
different weights to your data the
objective function change and your your
angle change so you can observe
different region different picture so
when you are adding 100 times and the 10
times to these two points the different
level curve I'll just write your right
hand side so you can solve different
type different pictures you can show
different pictures just like this so if
the main tougher let the data is your
object the average er is your objective
function if you represent what the
vision for the angle you observe the
world its most important thing we always
use a lot of parish like circular like
the like carrot or a lot of things yes
they can help you to solve things
quickly but they cannot let you to serve
the model you defined yeah so so how to
how to solve the show problem
which more much more approximate to the
real world it's much important it's
really really important so how to make
you a picture just like look like the
real world so the model is the outcome
so you can come out how things you can
control is the data and the literature
so it's very very important just like
look mate however they are here and the
Liberator is your angle and the law
outcome is our pictures ok I delete
things every day in a lot of business
problem area in e-commerce in trading or
in the newspaper and i will i will give
you a couple examples in lost kind of
area today so different angles create
different pictures that's engaging and
different questions creative a model is
in the earth science and what you
observe what future it's imposed yeah
it's the most important can say i want
to deliver today and the layout to kids
that can help you to apply your machine
animator in a real world more accuracy
accurate so the two kids is asked asking
question and finding solutions you can
see the right hand side is the question
part and the left hand side is the
solution part they are they can also
separate into the real world and also
the imaging words imagine word means the
most machine learning words and also the
mathematical words is the imaging words
we learn a lot of solving model TI from
the score or unlike Ortiz so so that we
can we can serve a lot of different kind
of machine and problem or different kind
of mathematical problem but thus if we
week
change the real work question into sort
of machine any questions or sort of
mathematical questions then we can solve
it by the scale we learned from school
but school didn't tell you school only
tell you when and where the algorithm
works well but Scotty and tell you when
and where it didn't didn't work anymore
yeah but I think that let that situation
it didn't wear any more is more
important to is worth source so that's
why I am here today to share this kind
of topic yeah and absolute combos the
problem you can solve by the skill you
learn in the school and after that you
need to compost compost your social
together and the bacteria were to check
is the solution to is the real solution
to a real question or you solve another
problem most of time we solve another
problem not not not directly to the
original program so let's in detail that
we choose a real problem and collected
the related data it is a modeling
procedural I I just one who's the
summarized song something like that I
just say and we choose a real question
and creatively rate created data and
also choose a major converted data to
vector of short answers and also the
converse the real problem to the stable
majority and the math problem and the
social machine learning problem
individually and the Cabal integrator
and finally the most important c is to
check is your solution the right list of
your problem okay i say a lot of words i
sing everyone a lot of people didn't
catch all this so we see one example is
a consultant
project oh no is not conservative
project it's a it's a project that we
help a newspaper phone to Bill layer
recommendation system so we can see how
we figure our recommendations it from
the sewer the modeling procedure is a
user-centered recommendation season that
you can see every individual user to
this pay phone they will see a different
we come as a result the recovery so
maybe maybe with the title that some
article you might be my interesting
something like this so it's the
architecture the naive art theater you
need to to get a new stay home feed and
you need to get the user behavior and
you need to build a responsive server
with high availability so and the most
important thing you need a backpack and
machine learning engine bhai all servers
so so it's a knife architecture to
recommend doing system and it can also
apply in different kind of area it can
also applying the e-commerce and also a
logging yeah and the first part of
modeling procedure is about the problem
and all the data so we can see for news
the recommendation season the LA basin
the most important business problem is
how to make users which mall news they
won't want to agree so how to achieve
this kind of be simple you need to to
kind of data the first kind of data is
news data but that you have the news
title and news body and the news time
and the category and the other is user
behavior data the user behavior data is
much more important to a news data that
can help you to decide which
you want to recommend to each individual
user so we quickly closed three types of
user behavior data the first type is
user view the news love you view action
the second type is collocation that use
a colleague load recommendation result
in the third is the most important thing
and a lot of people will [ __ ] a lot of
people always forget these kind of
things the user didn't click the link
when you are pushed can result to your
user that he may click one or not click
one not not really 100 play so if we
click one and the diamond 09 he didn't
click is really really important and the
most of an engineer will forget it they
recall on the the things that user click
so I highlight so let the second part of
modeling procedure is is how to make
your data through your lectures here we
have to kind of data the first kind of
data is text data so you can do a lot of
text mining will learn LP so you can
make your data into vector by turn
document matrix or you can use water
vector there are two links then you can
steal or examples all right hang poison
and the user behavior data you can also
use some some useful tools like spa
streaming or Kafka or the tutorial that
yesterday just tell us that there is a
try BB that you can use to to do it
events them holy and after you do the
ebay standpoint you can convert sort of
your use of behavior bulk into into
maybe user view or user click you'll use
a conch non click user item matrix
just like this this is using item asus
is user in your life society and the
button on top of the matrix so you can
control user item matrix and the item
item matrix that view at the view of the
viewer kalica at the view so you can
also come control the Q the Q with with
spurry with user item and time or user
item item at a time the four dimension
cube then it will help you to do the
following modeling things yeah at the
second part the server part is how to
convert your real problem tulip machine
bobbin and how to solve the mushroom
problem individually so the real problem
is how to make user which mall news they
want to read so we decompose the real
the piston problem into the stream
machining problem the first is the
hottest and the newest recommendation
with the commendation use users to greet
the hottest and the newest news so the
second part is content-based relation in
the surf rod is collaborative filtering
so the first of all the mathematical
become behind the first far is salting
so it's really easy to to find out what
is the newest news and what is the
hottest news and the low second part is
content-based creation is cross ring
after you share your data into a lecture
by 10 document matrix or the skills in
water vector you can do a lot of
culturing things something and you can
also do a party modeling it's the same
thing of catering and the talking model
is interesting so so but but different
the vectorization you do the same thing
on different vectors style
so sorry it's Chinese cover so is on
Chinese it is it's just do a cross ring
it is different cluster and the topic
and you can choose one article and find
out the most similar articles yeah and
the third problem is corrected
collaborative filtering you can do this
by metric vectorization or major
competition skill by solving this
objective function it is Greg you're
right regulate the Luger in turn ugly
this objective function is is in New
cradle it is the one known in your icon
wave space so it's not not original one
known here is new cleaner so so again
you can apply the lamesa to to an image
that with only twenty percent
information and very controlling so you
you can also use this kind of skill in
your cube or data matrix then you can
get the recommendation restore complete
your user ID matrix and you can get the
recommendation result the full part of
modeling procedure is it combined the
solution together and check it to a real
problem so there are two kind of measure
you can use here the first type of
measure is a simple example running you
just combine the week rinker together to
a strong anchor and the second kind of
major is reinforcement learning you can
you can use more user feedback after you
can combine out the example a new model
then you can improve so the first major
in symbol learning is help you to deal
with the statical combining combination
and the second ring post mending
it helps you to to deal with the problem
that you want to dynamically to
improvement your your model so so that's
too kind of Mesa and here we can see
that every News has is 10 scores it's
the sorting of time so the last score is
means the LA the newest news is so the
similarity score means that to two
articles how is the mirror to article so
so Lehrer is itself so they are to
rancor here to rancor here to whickering
her we control so we can easy to put the
weighted sum of two ringers to construct
a new wrinkle just the first wrinkle
point a multi-ply point stable and the
second rank of multi 4.3 then you can
control a new rinker and after you
control a new wrinkle then you can get a
new ring and you can also apply the week
rinker here and the strong linker so you
can control it given your network on top
of you you're weak link then you can get
a lot of strong linker so that's why a
lot of other things I do in Taiwan so
let me just a wreck help that the
modeling procedure has a seven-part the
first vice is about a problem the second
part is about data and the surprised at
how to make sure and the first part is
is Rio 2 machine learning and the fifth
part is soft machining problem and the
sex part is combine the solution
finalized check the solution
okay let's go to the most important part
of this poll is the brightness of the
modeling procedure so playtest biased of
each heart we are discussion so i will
give you a lot of the first part the
brain is of Bertha is from the problem
and data so there are two things but
they are highly related so the problem
you ask master relative look at how you
use to solve it so what kind of data you
must new you need to collect to solve
the problem it's it's a problem driven
thinking you using from problem and
wrong real problem what kind of data you
need to create it and some most of the
time alki has a lot of data a lot a lot
of data link from another sign they have
a lot of data they can sync with the
data what kind of problem they want to
solve but most of the time they like
this they tell you later they want to
sew problem a but actually I want to
solve problem B is the problem behind
Harbor yeah so so just like this so how
to find is that some blindness in your
data and the problem relationship so you
can check these two questions is there
some region information your data or
could the problem look cooler problem
answer by this data you can check these
two of questions in your modeling
procedures this is the largest bookstore
in Taiwan we help them to solve this
kind of problem so one day their major
as me that who you use our post data
to find some method that can help our
bookstore convert lost user who original
dislike us original dislike us so would
you think the post data has this
information if yes raise your hand also
if no press event so when why why do you
think there is no yeah yeah and two days
later the major Isaac me another
question could you use our post date
hard to find potential users so I asked
him could you define the potential he he
said the couple enjoy means user one
should buy it but lay heaven may be
posted have something information you
can do it with hot be talking things but
most of you sir they read the boot but
they didn't buy and the post there is no
raker in your post data that that's how
you wish which user which books your
bookstore so so I think Leah store still
no no information in your data yeah just
you can just do the retargeting yeah
here is the post data it generate the
tree the place generating data is the
important things that you can you need
to go there to fill in what kind of
situation that data comes from it is a
very important yeah I think that that
they have from toes can tell you on the
other information about the converted
user there is no information about this
like and unconverted but if you will
create an app let's help it help user
can scale
your boat and and match the command
interesting users look then then you can
get a lot of data from users and then
you can and you can get get the data
yeah so we can sync from the two English
away the first is they are even that you
have post data in a whole kind of
problem that you can serve and the last
second is the problem driven as you can
you can sing you can stay like the most
important property of all the bookstore
is how to gain their revenue and the
whole kind of data that can help it
learn to get in there criminy it is a
problem to driven the second case study
is doc engine based book search it's a
story about delicious is not delicious
because the dishes is a word and the
dishes is perceptions so use the 33
years ago my friend control
location-based book search service he
caught a lot of reviews and comments for
the restaurant from the website one day
he asked me hey George white white look
food my system recommend me that I think
all of this it is awful so so why quite
promises season grown so it's like I a
chain model with a long algorithm or is
that I use the wrong parameters and how
can i adjust it so I just answering that
it's not a mistake of your algorithm and
the parameters it's about the
information you want is not in your data
so delicious is a kind of reception and
it it's about of failing after you eat
sao paulo delicious is a word so which
you got a position then you write it
down
so they are in different classes the
words is inherit from the string and the
delicious is in here it from the
possession so so they are different
crossly so so you can think that the
perception is the first handed firsthand
data and the the string is the second
handed yeah so what what're you feel and
and how you how you cut it down and
enter the third but I things from the
data is about the bias of the data so so
if machine cannot learn by yourself it's
just like a child I learned by training
data sometimes you will change badly so
if you change your model with only black
speck black color background images then
it can distinguish the imaging with
white color background so it's also
important thing so the second part of
uprisings of modeling procedure comes
from the data vector so the plan is come
from the heart vector you need to answer
you your model this question is there
any information listing when you are
converting your data this is a unique
one unit growing example let's lay out
you to kind of string I love it and ill
of me is no no problem in English but
its generation problem in Chinese
because I and me are the same words in
their Chinese so they are generally the
same vector here so they generated no
difference vector so you cannot
distinguish these two sentence in this
kind of vector space so so it generates
on some trouble if we want to
distinguish length
so so it generates on brittany's and the
another brain is comes from your mental
concept it's the gap between the math
and the real words and when putting the
unique back so you can find it it's an
elementary school math 103-100 is equal
to six minus three is that you if you
think should raise your hand yeah but
when you put back the units so you will
see a different word yeah 103 Darrow's
minus 100 are equal to let's take sorry
minus three dollars but 123 dollars
dark- 100 are stark you think the
difference of 103 stark dar Adal is is
three percent buzzer behind blue eyes is
100 person so so it's difference so you
cannot use this kind of coordinator
cannot 822 analysis analysis your data
so you need to change another college so
which coordinate is most proper
coordinated for analysis stock data is a
real difficult problem if you are
interesting in this part you can
discolor with me as am I talk and the
third brandon is it comes from the
transformation of your Maj Rainey
problem it comes from the frameworks the
brain is of reassuring frameworks the
brightness of reclassification and the
broadness of crossing imaging now you
each an orange in April cast fire and
the cars were just made a banana then
then the car i will recognize burner is
orange or april so how to solve this
kind of
this kind of problem is also generating
the digital crossfire middle of a bait
so it's it's a model I contract with the
deep neural network it get ninety-eight
percent accuracy in the maintenance the
data but when it made other bait then
it's it doesn't work so how to how to
stop the time carbon and for a cross
ring we always want to force to point in
the stem pro cursor but we cannot do
list in carcery so how can I do this the
keyway the key fact is we always meet
some data with labels instantly how we
thought so we cannot use only supervised
learning or only unsupervised into
perfect of our visiting problem we can
not use this so how how can how the the
label propagation and how to detect the
new labels is the most important to
questions to serve if we want to serve
the reopening problem so the new data a
new labels are coming all the way in the
e-commerce to retailers and the
newspaper owns because there are a lot
of new products in e thomas new hair
every day a lot of in amazon and a lot
of news generate every day in your new
spray foam so you comes from a lot of
new category a lot of new cable news
together with products so so it is
really really important to solve this
kind of problem so how to solve we need
we can use to kind of approach the first
approach is used crossfire just like
cross ring laser it's cold in
incremental crossfire you can use one
versus all CalFire to build an
incremental crossfire analyst taken is
used across during measured
just like a car fire is measure learning
so a inner incremental transpire you can
short to crossfire when vs all the first
is April is April or not able the second
is orange not orange so if you love
banana in the post rejections area then
it generates a new crosser so you can
use your crossfire you just do things
like you do cross by culturing so
another thing is metric learning how to
use me this is the most it is the most i
like the this kind of algorithm and I
use most in our production and what is
Magic learning you learn a passing
definite matrix that help you to compute
the distance in an other way so you in a
Euclidean distance the Ray Ray and the
pro point are near to the center
greenpoint user the Euclidean distance
to compute but if we change you change
another decent computing method then
it's changing it push out the blue point
and push all the rate point and they
pour the thinker account so we know that
if we have a positive anime matrix we
can decompose it into two matrix and
make the transformation so you can do
list and and another is mo is then which
sandwich data stays in center which you
de la say after the transformation your
data will become here you can use gaming
country to to do the classified
crossfire doing yeah yeah okay it is
almost n
so accurately you can you can use the
neural network to control metric
learning start actually you can use and
the metric learning will give you an
order view point to see the world it is
always giving me so remember that
whatever you observe in a holy with
three you too I think for your attention
yeah that's why I put this right now
picture because i want to remind me that
every one has its own brand x so so so
do i so unless i can understand more
about my brownies I cannot overcome the
challenge so so that's why I assure this
to everyone the enjoyed thank you